now let's have a look at all of this and
let me try and explain what it's about I
have made this Milken it's not my best
work but it's the legible I think in the
defendant reason to me here's much of
inequalities okay
what's all this work about I'm just
trying to get the boundaries that's it
okay you can see how I'm gonna shading
on there I'm gonna get to that pot in a
second so I just worked out because the
circle was in nice form there's my
center radius this is about finding out
where the circle hits the axes okay the
horizontal ones are easy the vertical
ones you've got some surge so that's why
I had to go through this what's this big
one mess here you can blame the fact
that I didn't use last numbers if I
chose next time is these are all the
integers but as it is I mean I've seen
something like this before and it's not
what am i doing I'm trying to find where
this diagonal line should have another
diagonal a little bit um the boundary
right the video boundary where does it
intersect with this circular manner
that's all okay and it turns out to be
some not particularly nice points but
you do have to find what they are I've
made them hollow circles in the moment
cuz I don't know whether they're gonna
be filled or not there'll be a good
reason to think they weren't be okay now
that I've got my boundaries what do I do
I want to know each boundary divides up
with a plane into different sections
right so with this line you can go up or
down so let's think about that we want
to know which area so how do you do can
you find out which one it is what are
you just test a point okay and then
easiest point you can get is the origin
all right so let's put in zero zero okay
zero zero zero is less than or equal to
two so I greater than two minus here is
that true no it is not so the origin is
not in the region were interested in so
we're looking up okay now normally you
would after you shave that part I'm not
gonna do that now cuz I'm gonna make a
a disaster of my graph but I just want
to keep in my head okay therefore above
above the straight line okay now after
that I think either circle so have a
look at this right less than an iron now
again you can test the point okay but I
think there's a better way to do it you
can reason through what does this mean
okay what possible values could this
happen so you have eight point nine or
eight seven or six they'd all be fine
what what does this number mean this
number on the right hand side has a has
an effect right what's it about it
defines the radius squared right so as
this number gets smaller the radius gets
smaller so in other words what this
means is all of the circles that have a
radius less than three okay so it's
inside the circle that's what I'm taking
off okay so I think that's fast I'm more
intuitive than testing appointment okay
so I'm above the straight line I'm
inside the circle right
and that'll yeah with the testing
question your head right just just like
that
really and usually it's quite trivial as
opposed to this stuff which if I did in
my head I don't have problems so all
right now which pot is that that looks
like at this part to me okay
so now that I've got my main area I just
have to check the boundaries of which
parts are important the circle doesn't
include the boundary so I'm just gonna
leave that dotted a straight line though
does include right so the straight line
part of it will be filmed now those
endpoints which hope its is so much
trouble to find these three Umbra
trabajo okay um are they going to be
filled or are they going to be Hollow
well when I look at a point right it
would satisfy this inequality but it
won't satisfy this one right because
it's not including the boundary right so
those polar circles I'm gonna leave it
okay just to remind you since they're
both not inclusive they'll be Hollow
okay lots of little things to fall into
so just be careful okay